Rand Paul has had a busy couple of
months in April the junior senator from
Kentucky announced that he was
officially running for president in May
he released his new book taking a stand
which argues that only a new kind of
Republican can win a general election
against Hillary Clinton in part by
embracing such cross partisan issues as
privacy as he did most famously in a
March 2013 filibuster about drone policy
and as the clock struck down to June
Paul fulfilled a campaign vow and pissed
off a lot of Republicans including
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
and much of the 2016 presidential field
my blocking reauthorization of the
Patriot Act we sat down with Rand Paul
in his campaign office Thursday to talk
about his ongoing disputes with GOP
hawks like Lindsey Graham whether Edward
Snowden should go to prison and what
will be the future of NSA surveillance
Senator Paul thanks for joining us glad
to do you block the Patriot Act
reauthorization at midnight before June
1st we have about 40 hours later our
freedom 40 hours will be relied only on
the Constitution we survived for 40
hours with barely survived those 40
hours a bill passes that you oppose
because you thought it didn't go far
enough and now the administration is
petitioning the FISA Court to reanimate
the bulk collection of metadata how much
after all this exertion did freedom win
you know I think there were some
successes the USA Freedom Act that
passed
ends the bulk collection by government
so the government will no longer be
collecting your phone records and
sending them to Utah now the question is
is how will it transform and will they
still be collecting my understanding is
the NSA lives at the telephone company
already all right they're there they
have a portal they have computers they
suck up all your phone data every day as
soon as you make it they suck up all
your phone records and then now they've
been pushing send and it goes to Utah I
think they will no longer push send but
I think it will still be on an SNS a
computer and I think be an interesting
question to ask and I don't know this
absolutely but my understanding is
probably it's still gonna sit on a
computer that computers not gonna be in
Utah it's gonna be at the phone company
I think it still sits on my guest as a
government computer it will still
so Paulist Adam the other thing is is
right before the Patriot Act the many
people the people who love surveillance
of Americans phone records were
complaining we weren't getting enough
they said we were only collecting 20 or
30 percent of the cellphone records one
interesting question will be under the
new format will they actually be
collecting more of your cellphone data
because they now will have a more direct
communication through the phone company
do you see in your book that the in
George Orwell's 1984 is not hyperbole
and that it's possible that they're
collecting information on every single
American do you still think that's true
today yeah and I think the thing is when
I was a kid read 1984 in the 1970s
probably I say I was somewhat comforted
because we didn't have the technology to
spy on everybody all the time now I
think we literally do have the
technology you know in a large amount of
data can and information can be gotten
from metadata some people say oh I was
just boring old medical or of boring old
business records but the thing is you
put it all together and a lot can be
determined about a person many people
are telling me they think the phone
records is just the tip of the iceberg
that through the executive order one two
three three three they're actually
collecting much more maybe text messages
maybe email email after six months even
the content you know so they say oh
we're not collecting content of
conversations well I think a good
question would be what about content of
email after six months they say it has
no protections they also will tell you
general Hayden wrote this in time two
days ago he said you know what Fourth
Amendment doesn't protect records at all
that's the the commanding case here is
Maryland versus Smith and Fourth
Amendment doesn't protect you at all
that worries me I think we need to have
another ruling at the Supreme Court
level because I think the information in
the cloud should get the same amount of
protection as information in the castle
a person who is of some importance who
has endorsed you for president used
words like demagoguery and campaign of
disinformation this week have you
certainly that been referring to me
must have been somebody else have you
talked to Mitch McConnell this week we
have we have we are on good personal
terms and we disagree on this issue but
I'm also happy to have the debate I
think if you get outside the Beltway and
you ask people do you think the
government's gone too far on this I
think overwhelmingly the public sides
with me
there was a poll about a week ago and
said people under 40 do you think the
government's gone too far and collecting
your phone records 83% of people under
40 believe that and so I think I'm in
good company you said on in the heat of
battle that you thought that maybe some
of the people in the pro surveillance
side wish that something bad would
happen a terrorist attack would happen
to prove their point do you actually
think that was it a heat of the battle
moment I think that might have been
hyperbole and sometimes you get your
juices flowing and I was at the at the
moment it appeared that they were trying
not to let me speak and that may have
been overstatement and it is how can I
know the motives of people and what they
believe but I do think that people use
fear to try to allow government to grow
larger and that the surveillance state
and Patriot Act and all of that stuff
has come out of fear and I want people
to know that you can stop terrorists you
can collect the records of terrorists
using the Fourth Amendment in fact I
I've asked that question of former NSA
officials can you get more information
with a constitutional warrant the judges
warrant or with metadata and they so
much more with a warrant and so almost
all of these cases we've had some
information on the terrorists before
even 9/11 we had a great deal of
information we had captured the 20th
hijacker
and a traditional warrant I think could
have gotten is information and where I
don't want to be misinterpreted as
someone who wouldn't give permission for
that if I were the judge and you came to
me the FBI agent did this and asked for
permission to look at misawa's records a
month before 9/11 I'm a yes I'm a yes to
look at the records of people you have
suspicions but I'm a no if you want to
generally collect everyone's records
particularly of people who for whom you
have no suspicion Chris Christie said
that you and Mike Lee are on the side of
Edward Snowden you write about Edward
Snowden pretty interesting Lee
book comparing him to Director of
National Intelligence James clapper
I think the framing is the the leaker
and the liar I if you know on the day
after inauguration you get a phone call
and it's Edward Snowden saying all right
I'm ready to come back what do you do
you know I think justice is about making
punishment proportional to the crime and
I think his intentions were to reveal
something that he felt like the people
in government were lying about and it
turns out they were lying the Director
of National Intelligence committed
perjury in front of the Senate committee
my understanding is it's about a
five-year sentence but instead of
getting any kind of sentence instead of
getting a slap on the risk or instead of
even being fired he's been rewarded and
he's still in charge of intelligence and
I think he's done a great deal to
damaged trust on the other side of the
coin
can you let people who have sensitive
data just make the decision to reveal it
to the world I think you have to have
laws against that so I think there have
to be laws against what Snowden did did
he do it for a higher purpose does he
have a high moral ground all of that I
think history will judge but I sort of
tongue-in-cheek said that if I had the
choice I'd put clapper and Snowden in
the same jail cell for about the same
period of time that's not a serious
question but I think it would be an
interesting debate they might have about
you know Liberty versus security I guess
the question is would you have to put a
microphone in there and no but they
probably could have a reality jail-cell
show and they'd probably you know
bestseller no I think that there has to
be some punishment what that is but I
think the other side has been crazy over
the top that people say they want to
shoot Snowden or they want to hang him
or that you know I think that one of the
things that we've tried to promote is a
reform that would make things different
Snowden has said he would have tried
official channels to reveal this to
someone officially but that the
whistleblower statute doesn't apply to
contractors so I actually have an
amendment that would try to make that so
so if you're a contractor doing business
with the intelligence agency and you
find that they're breaking the law and
interestingly the courts have now said
the NSA is breaking the law it's my
other pet peeve with the president
this whole thing president says Oh will
you know he accuses me of getting in the
way of performance like you could have
stopped the program anytime you wanted
you did it through executive order and
you were doing it through executive
action we never told you to do this
program in fact even the authors of the
Patriot Act say they never intended to
give you this power and yet you won't
stop it until we actually affirmative ly
tell you to stop it so I think the
president's not quite sincere you know
in wanting real reform speaking of
people who want to lock up Edward
Snowden in in in a brig Lindsey Graham
said as a part of his critique of your
performance that you're more scared of
the NSA than you are of Isis is that
true you know I think there are people
who you have to consider the source you
know this is a person who said that he
would use censorship if he needed to
this is the same person who said well
when people ask for an attorney you
should tell him to shut up this is the
same person who's also said that you
know you know they asked for a judge
just drone them I mean some of the stuff
I doing doesn't rise beyond sort of
middle school kind of rhetoric and so
it's hard to know when to respond to
people like that but I think ultimately
if you want to talk among adults about
is Isis a threat to our country yes it's
NSA a threat sometimes to our Liberty
yes I personally don't think you have to
trade one for the other I don't think
you have to trade your liberty for
security I think you can have both I
think the Constitution can be a powerful
tool the Constitution never said we
wouldn't go after records of criminals
or of terrorists Constitution just says
you have to individualize the suspicion
put a person's name on it I tell people
I want to collect more records of
terrorists just less records of innocent
Americans would if Lindsey Graham became
the nominee which is really likely to
happen would Rand Paul's important you
know I'm a Republican and I will support
whoever the Republican nominee is
fortunately we have a long way between
here and there and you know we have a
real shot
you know most recent CNN poll had us
tied for the lead so we're gonna keep
fighting for that but I
ever since I ran for office I've always
said I'll you know when I ran for the
Senate I'm a support who wins your pitch
is for being a new kind of Republican
privacy certainly is one of these issues
that you think you can pull people who
are not traditionally in the Republican
field and even you know talking about
these polls your head-to-head poll
matchups with Hillary or is good with
anybody else's out there but you also
have to run a primary campaign in a
Republican field so what are some of the
biggest issues that are similar to
privacy that differentiates you as a new
kind of Republican that can pull new
constituencies in and that you will be
emphasizing of although we've worked for
the last two years or maybe longer on
criminal justice issues and I think
these do bring new people in I think
that putting someone in jail for 15
years for a drug possession or use or
sale crime is ridiculous I was in
Missouri not too long ago and there's a
gentleman there who's been in jail I
think for 25 years and he has a life
sentence for sale of marijuana and
finally the governor just gave him a
pardon the president has given some
pardons also there's still people in
jail for crack cocaine for like you know
15 years whereas the powder cocaine
equivalent would have been six months to
a year I'm forgetting those people
second chance and I think these criminal
justice issues do bring some new people
and frankly the Democrats haven't been
very good on these issues you know Bill
Clinton was a big promoter of most of
the draconian drug laws that have put
people away forever
so I think giving people a second chance
and understanding that people make
mistakes when their kids should get a
another chance is something that opens
our party to a whole new audience that
hasn't considered Republicans perform
quick follow a lot of talk I did with
Baltimore murder rate starting to
skyrocket in New York elsewhere Fox is
going overtime these days with you know
all these criminal justice reform things
are now ushering in a new crime wait how
do you respond to people who want to put
the brakes on your project there for
that reason I don't know that there's
really been a lot of criminal justice
reform that could be equated with a you
know skyrocketing crime rate most of the
murder rates over decades have been
actually going down there can be a
variety of reasons why any kind of
you know one month trend of anything
probably isn't much of value
statistically I do think that one of the
biggest problems our cities have and I
saw this with Baltimore in the other day
is that unemployment in Baltimore and
the inner city is greater than it was in
the Great Depression so I think one of
the debates we need to have in our
country is that the war on poverty big
government New Deal kind of stuff with
government's gonna coddle you from
cradle to grave hasn't really worked and
I don't think people are better off and
I was in Chicago in the South Side about
a week ago and it was amazing to me how
many people came to me in Englewood when
the most dangerous neighborhoods in
America one of the poorest neighborhoods
in America came up to me and said you
know what when the government tries to
give us money the Machine rips it off
anyway the people in the government
unions take it all it's all taken
through patronage and it's interesting
people write about the fact how unions
often excluded minorities and we're when
they first started really meant to
exclude blacks from the Union completely
many African Americans still believe in
a very visceral way and are seeing it
that the unions are meant to exclude
them from participation particularly the
government unions and also really that
they prevent the money over getting to
the source the money gets passed out as
political favoritism but never really
gets to the people anyway very good well
thank you very much for joining us again
and thank you
[Music]